Les Tepulton se préparaient à voir leur famille s’agrandir
"C'est quoi ça ?"
"Tim!"
"On te présente ton petit frère"
Mais le bébé se préparait à autre chose...
"Nous les bébés, on est en pleine crise !"
"Les bébés ne reçoivent pas autant d'amour qu'autre fois."
"Je vous présente notre ennemi mortel :
le bébé chien."
"Haaaaan"
"Non !
Vous voyez ? C'est ça le problème !
"Vous avez appris quelque chose?"
"A, B, C, D !"
"Non! Avez-vous des infos sur les bébés chiens?"
"Gentil bébé chien !"
"Non Jimbo ! Les bébés chiens sont démoniaques!"
"Stacy, relisez-moi vos notes!"
"Je sais pas lire.. Qu'est-ce que ça dit?"
"Patron ! Les parents !"
"Trop chou !"
"On dirait qu'ils sont à leur petite table de réunion."
"Qui veut du dessert?"
"C'est atrocement humiliant!"
Je suis le bébé qu'il vous faut pour ce job.
Je sais que cette mission est capitale pour la société.
Tu sais parler !
AHHHHHH Caca Prout
Faut que je m'occupe du G.A.M.I.N.
Mais qui es-tu ?
Je suis chargé de mission. Il n'y a pas assez d'amour pour tout le monde.
Mon boulot c'est de trouver pourquoi.
Va me chercher un double expresso et vois si y'a des bons sushis dans le quartier.
Je tuerais pour un rouleau de thon tataki au sésame !
Maman ! Papa ! Le bébé parle !
La guerre est déclarée.
Lâche ça ! Espèce de ...
- Regarde ! Les enfants ont fini par s'entendre !
- C'est formidable !
Si je loupe cette mission,
il faudra que je vive avec toi pour toujours !
Ok je te donne un coup de main !
Mais seulement si tu fiches le camp après.
Ça roule.
Voilà le petit train qui arrive !
Non ... non !
Ils nous regardent ...
Tchou tchou !
Okaaay.
Prends ça dans le tchou tchou.
Comment on fait pour passer devant le garde ?
Je n'ai jamais connu une telle humiliation de ...
TOUTE MA VIE !
Je mettrai pas le costume de marin !
Mais si tu vas le mettre !
Pourquoi t'as éteint la lumière ? Ouh !
Qu'est-ce que c'est que tout ce bruit ?
Vous avez vu comme il est mignon?
Ohhh ! J'en ai un pour toi aussi !
Quoi ?!
Pas de bol !
DreamWorks - Baby Boss
Pose ce biscuit tout de suite !
Les biscuits, c'est pour les gagnants.